let's talk about the 2018 midterms that
we've learned over the weekend that
officials are planning to close almost
all of the polling places in a mostly
black part of Georgia meaning a mostly
left-leaning part of Georgia for the
upcoming November midterms and you might
remember some time ago we covered the
story of the Supreme Court killing some
parts of the Voting Rights Act and there
was a part of the Voting Rights Act that
required preclearance when certain
states wanted to change things like
exactly what Georgia is doing and the
idea for that preclearance rule in the
beginning was you have States which
historically have not been particularly
friendly to the voting rights of
individuals particularly minorities and
those who are underprivileged so if they
want to change the rules related to
voting they need to clear those rules in
advance they can't just change them
supposedly we didn't need that anymore
and in fact that was the reason that the
Supreme Court struck down certain parts
of the Voting Rights Act they said we're
beyond that phase in American history
nobody's really going to do this and
then of course Georgia does exactly that
we've talked about voter suppression as
one of these meta issues right whether
you care about the environment education
social issues gay rights whatever
campaign finance is a meta issue that
impacts all political issues voter
suppression is another one of those net
neutrality and of course climate change
our meta issues that influence every
political issue and what we now have
found out is that in Randolph County
Georgia which is more than 60% black
more than 30% in poverty there are nine
polling places seven of which election
officials are saying we're going to
close some of those polling places being
closed aren't just sixty percent black
they are more than 96 percent black now
the explanation from those election
officials for closing these aren't we
don't want black people to vote they
would never say that even if that's the
truth the explanation is that these
seven polling places are accessible
enough to people with disabilities and
this is like a perfect foil it's a
brilliant justification because they can
say hey
we want ad a accessibility for all these
polling places some of them aren't a DA
accessible so we're going to shut them
down now the ACLU has immediately
activated and they're saying it doesn't
matter what reason they give for closing
these polling places this effectively
discriminates against black voters and
poor voters if you're poor you're also
less likely to have a car
meaning that you're not going to be able
to get to the two of nine polling places
that are going to stay open so let's
unravel the logic here sort of piece by
piece first of all the claim is seven
polling places aren't a DEA compliant so
we're gonna shut them down okay number
one it's not news that those seven
polling places aren't a DEA compliant
they could have already been fixed but
they weren't but then we get to the key
part do you have to close a polling
place because it's not a DEA compliant
the answer is obviously no let's assume
you can't make them compliant by
Election Day it's already almost
September let's assume that that's true
they're not going to be compliant by the
day of the November election well then
you can arrange for people to still show
up at those polling places and if they
need assistance if they can't vote there
because of the lack of a DEA compliance
you bring them to a compliant polling
place or maybe you make arrangements to
have you know like if it's stairs that
are the problem in the building yeah you
set up outdoor tents where people can
vote without having to get a wheelchair
up a flight of stairs for example or
maybe you get every registered voter an
absentee ballot with return postage paid
so that they don't need to go to the
polling place at all you don't close the
whole thing down and then of course we
get to the reality the reality is that
Stacey Abrams it's gonna be on the
ballot in the fall she's the first black
nominee for governor from a major party
in Georgia and lo and behold immediately
right wing election officials want to
make it more difficult for black people
to vote shocking that they would try to
close down seven of nine polling places
in one of the few more liberal parts of
Georgia which Obama won in 2008 and
Obama won in 2012 and Hillary won over
Trump in twenty
sixteen and then where do we end back up
at the Supreme Court the Supreme Court
which Donald Trump increasingly controls
the Supreme Court which previously
decided we don't need the Voting Rights
Act anymore or at least certain parts of
it because nobody would try this stuff
anymore anyway and that's why when you
hear from people that it doesn't really
matter that Trump gets one too however
many Supreme Court picks he's ultimately
going to get this is why it matters
because Supreme Court's regularly make
decisions and then we sort of forget
about it and then a couple years go by
and then all of a sudden
seven of nine polling places in a
democratic african-american poor area of
Georgia which could maybe lead to a
democratic Georgia governor get closed
down and we don't have that preclearance
law anymore this is why this stuff
matters
yeah this is what Republicans are good
at fighting dirty right whether it's
gerrymandering or voter suppression this
is just what they do right and it's
because they can't win the hearts and
minds of voters it looks like there will
be a blue wave in 2018 although we don't
know for sure their president isn't very
popular their ideas aren't very popular
so this is what they have to go with
this is what they have to resort to yeah
I mean while on the west coast which is
not in play for Republicans it's vote my
mail with automatic voter registration
here in Massachusetts our Republican
governor Charlie Baker just signed into
law automatic voter registration when
you get to get your driver's license in
places where you can win with these
methods you see them actually used in
places where one side or the other is
holding a very very clear advantage all
of a sudden automatic voter registration
or vote-by-mail or more polling places
or early voting isn't controversial
anymore this is why it matters and you
know I talk about this every couple
months whether we're close to an
election or not and every time I talk
about it I say if we wait until two
months before the election it's probably
too late and that's probably the case
here although hopefully the ACLU will be
able to do something about it but the
problem is even when I badger the
audience about it two years out from an
election it doesn't seem as urgent
because we are still got to
and it's this catch-22 where we can't
seem to get anything done follow the
show on Instagram if you are not
following david pakman show on instagram
you were not getting behind-the-scenes
pictures you are not getting your
questions answered by me multiple times
per week we're taking audience questions
on instagram so please follow the show
on instagram a david pakman show you can
also follow me on instagram at david dot
pakman very very exciting stuff going on
there I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a
really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka Steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks i'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube i've put a link in the
description i have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to blink accom slash
Pakman that's bli nki st.com /p a que ma
n